E aí
[Música]
Oi é bom dia boa noite boa tarde meu
nome é Gilberto Chagas eu sou catador de
material reciclável faço parte do
movimento nacional dos catadores em Kate
e rede cata Unidos aqui de Belo
Horizonte e é hoje né as pessoas me
perguntam né sobre transformação né sua
história de vida né Muita gente me
pergunta a Gilberto como você chegou até
aí como você se tornou né liderança como
vocês né ah eu vou me lembrando quando
eu penso nisso eu me lembro do ano de
1985 né quando tudo começou eu lembro
que eu devia ter uns 10 10 para 11 anos
né E aí a gente tava com vontade de
comer uma Martha Rocha minha tinha um
amigo meu lá no bairro Durval de Barros
fica lá em Contagem e a gente falou Pô
cara comer uma Martha Rocha não é para
quem não sabe Martha Rocha é um pão né
nos outros estados é é um pão recheado
porque chamam de sonho né E aí a gente
não tinha grana né a gente que moleque
aí tinha uma algumas construções lá no
bairro Jardim Riacho e a gente saiu para
coletar marmitex né aquelas embalagem
que pessoal põe o almoço então e a gente
ficou o dia inteiro coletando àquelas
embalagens coletando com e a gente
coletou dois sacos e a gente chegou no
ferro velho chega no ferro velho de
exame aquele negócio aí que a gente
constatou não dava para comprar Martha
Rocha né e sim 85 né aí lembrando eu tô
vendo o tanto que eu sou velho né porque
era na época do Cruzeiro ainda e o cara
ficou sensibilizada que a gente fala pow
a gente queria comprar uma matar Rocha
eu não sei o quê aí o cara falou não eu
vou complementar o dinheiro para vocês e
tal e a gente foi lá comprar o Marta
Rocha né os 9 anos né mas nove anos não
mais tarde né a gente começou é coletar
o material reciclável né ia lá uns 15
vocês moleque lá para o bairro Novo
Riacho pega algum carrinho aí Aquele
monte de menino né aí coletando sucata
coleção do Papel a gente batia nas casas
né pedir a comida pediu para o velho né
tinha uma coisa você tá pedindo tão
velho Ah tá pedindo para o velho né E aí
a gente foi nisso e eu fui levando minha
vida assim né aí vem um e tenta né chega
os anos 90 eu me torno adolescente Ah eu
já com 15 16 17 anos né e continua na
catação só que aí eu comecei a trabalhar
também outros setores também né eu fui
trabalhar na construção civil né só que
é uma coisa engraçada eu nunca consegui
trabalhar assim for é no mercado formal
de trabalho eu nunca consegui por
exemplo me adaptar um sistema né eu
tinha que há 7 horas você tem que estar
aqui você tem que almoçar 11 horas você
vai sair 5:00 5 horas da tarde né e
chega no final de semana não é aquele
pouquinho de dinheiro eu levo assim
falar o cara eu não posso ficar nisso
não e aí era construção civil é catação
ferro velho catação catação ferro velho
né aí vem os anos 2000 chegando dois mil
aí eu já lá com os meus 25 anos de idade
né 25 anos de idade
Aí a gente foi abordado na rua por uma
alguma senhorinhas bom né Elas eram lá
da igreja que o Salvador né Paróquia que
Salvador lá da igreja católica elas
falaram para a gente assim olha você
sabia que vocês fazem um serviço muito
relevante para a sociedade Como assim
Dona não porque se você escolher esse
material aí e é o seguinte a prefeitura
deixa de ter gasto né Vocês tão ajudando
o meio ambiente vocês são prestando um
serviço para Cidade esse trabalho suas é
importante a gente tem que ir lá na
prefeitura é fazer reivindicação é pedir
para ajudar os catadores e tal aí a
gente pensa assim Ah cara isso é ano
eleitoral isso é campanha política esse
povo aí tá com nada não beleza ficamos
nessa quando foi 2001 a gente começou a
participar de algumas reuniões né A
gente achou interessante a gente acabou
indo aí pessoal participar dessas
reuniões lá na casa do movimento popular
lá em contagem Aí chegou lá o pessoal
começou a falar de sobre associativismo
cooperativismo
né eles falaram que teve uma grande
marcha em Brasília em 2011 Os catadores
foram assunto teve mais de 2 mil
catadores lembra e em alguns catadores
que estavam lá né eles tinham ido nessa
masha é Instalado não tinha muito
catador a gente foi em Brasília e não
sei o que não sei o que a gente lá né
participando e tal e aí beleza a gente
gostou muito e ele começou a voltar e
todo sábado tinha essas reuniões né E aí
eu comecei a me interessar por aquilo né
E aí o pessoal foi me chamando cada vez
mais cada vez mais e aí eu lembro que eu
fiz a minha primeira viagem né o pessoal
falou assim o gilberta é tem uma pauta
lá em Brasília né sobre resíduos óleo
sobre a Lei Nacional de resíduos sólidos
eles vão aprovar essa lei vai ajudar os
catadores aquela coisa que você não quer
ir lá em Brasília para poder conversar
com os deputados eu falei Vão bora lá né
nessa época eu não tinha essa dimensão
né Essa da importância né não era um tão
politizado assim eu pensei comigo uma
viagem graça eu vou lá né conhecer
Brasília não nunca nunca fui em Brasília
aí a gente foi Bom vamos lá conversando
lá com os parlamentares aquela coisa
toda com esse Brasília beleza de lá para
cá a gente começou a atuar aí surgiu né
as máquinas Associação dos catadores de
material reciclável lado de Contagem e a
gente conseguiu organizar e tal a
prefeitura eles um convênio aquela coisa
toda né e a gente começou em 2002 se
inaugura o primeiro galpão né lá no
bairro Novo Riacho E aí beleza a gente
achou a nosso problema essa tudo
resolvido a gente tem o galpão agora a
gente vai ser feliz e e beleza mas só
que aí a gente viu que não era bem assim
né tinha muitas coisas a gente ainda
dependia do atravessador a gente ainda
não consegui vender o material por um
preço bom a gente tinha as questões
internas dentro da associação né e
Através disso a gente foi se politizam
cada vez mais né a gente começou a
participar de bastante curso né E aí vem
a questão da transformação de vida e não
é porque antes é eu não eu por exemplo
não tinha uma perspectiva né Eu achava
que a eu vou ficar nessa eu não vou não
você ninguém na vida né que quando as
pessoas falam assim a você vai ser
alguém na vida a sociedade tem muita
essa coisa você vai ter um super emprego
você vai ter um super carro você vai ter
um supersalário né você vai ter uma
super casa não né
Se alguém na vida é você adquirir
conhecimento né você adquirir é uma base
na vida né
conhecimento
trabalhar junto com pessoas né
começa a ter outros ideais né então o
ideal que eu tenho presença do trabalho
coletivo né junto com os catadores nunca
esquentadores e Através disso a gente
foi começando a caminhar Quando forem
2003 né Mais ou menos o pessoal me
chamou falou Alberto a gente está
criando uma comissão Estadual do
movimento nacional dos catadores
o movimento nasceu em 2001 lá naquela
marcha de Brasília né que a gente tinha
falado né E aí o pessoal começou a me
chamar eu comecei a participar das
reuniões né das formação política né das
formações técnicas né das formações de
negócio o negócio social né não é essa
coisa do negócio é só do mercado só de
ganhar dinheiro não mas é um negócio
social é um negócio que inclui o negócio
aqui faz as pessoas trabalharem né E aí
a gente começou ali e aí começou a minha
formação a transformação de vida né é eu
sempre faço uma analogia com as pessoas
por exemplo é tudo se transforma nela
você e se fala né nada se perde tudo se
transforma então por exemplo você pega a
mão não vamos fazer uma comparação aqui
pelos por aí eu tenho uma garrafa PET né
bom imaginar que eu tô segurando uma
garrafa PET uma garrafa de refrigerante
aquela garrafa ela foi petróleo um dia
né então é
transformou pegou o petróleo transformou
em plástico que transformou em garrafa
aí já foi tendo a as ações essa garrafa
foi para o mercado aí ela foi comprada
para alguém né mas o destino dessa
garrafa e vai depender daquela pessoa
que adquiriu aquela garrafa ela vai ela
vai ser uma festa de criança Ela vai
para uma festa de empresa ela vai para
casa ela vai pra algum lugar né ou a
pessoa pode simplesmente usar essa
garrafa e jogar pela janela do carro né
ô ô a pessoa pode pegar essa garrafa mas
a jogar no lixo é no lixo comum resíduos
no lixo doméstico ou a pessoa pode
encaminhar essa garrafa para reciclagem
nela pode encaminhar lá para Associação
cooperativa entregar um catador e essa
garrafa ela vai virar outra coisa ela
vai virar outra garrafa ela vai virar
tecido ela vai virar a peça né então
isso é a transformação na vida da gente
a gente também passa por essas
transformações a gente tem várias
direções né pode ter um pode ser uma
transformação de vida boa pode ser uma
transformação de vida ruim pode ter uma
transformação de vida mas é né E no meu
caso é eu vejo que eu tive uma
transformação de vida é boa né E aí
Através disso eu consegui realizar
alguns sonhos né através desse trabalho
junto é a coleta seletiva reciclagem
nessa coisa de tá dentro do movimento
nacional dos catadores né eu consegui
realizar algumas coisas né Eu sempre
gostei de fotografia Né desde menino né
nos anos 90 por exemplo a gente comprava
aquelas máquinas fotográficas no camelô
né aí tinha que comprar máquina
fotográfica tinha que comprar o filme né
Aí você tinha que fazer as fotos aí você
tinha que rezar pelas fotos não saiu
ruim ou a foto não quer mate umas fotos
lá que saía né não é igual Hoje você
pega o celular e tira selfie você faz a
foto e tal aquela coisa toda não mas eu
sempre gostei de fotografia né Eu sempre
gostei de fotografia porque quando eu
coletava eu achava revistas né que as
revistas lá né aí eu ficava olhando
aquelas fotos do natureza fotos de
pessoa a foto bacana fazendo uma cara um
dia você fotógrafo de natureza um dia eu
vou sair viajando pelo mundo né
fotografando eu adoro fotografia E aí
beleza quando for em 2005 eu entrei de
cabeça na questão da fotografia e aí eu
comecei ver as pessoas ali dentro do
galpão eu comecei a viajar bastante né
eu comecei a ir para outros estados né
através desse trabalho junto ao
movimento nacional dos catadores eu
comecei a conhecer pessoas e aí eu pude
começar a registrar as pessoas né aí era
uma máquina Zinha emprestada né E aí
quando a gente fala de transformação é
tudo isso por exemplo né transformação
tecnológica deu oportunidade por exemplo
pelo ser fotógrafo não é porque antes
você não tinha acesso né Você vai
comprar uma máquina fotográfica muito
cara você vai comprar né eu não tinha aí
ver a
digitalização né E aí abriu abriu portas
daí eu comprei minha primeira máquina eu
consegui comprar minha primeira máquina
com E aí comecei registrar e eu registro
hoje eu faço o registro de pessoas né Eu
adoro fotografar pessoas eu me descobri
querendo fotografar pessoas né
fotografar suas lutas fotografia né
então eu consigo fazer essas imagens né
de lá para cá eu comecei a registrar as
pessoas né e através desse trabalho da
fotografia me abriu algumas portas né eu
consegui fazer para conseguir viajar por
exemplo alguns países né Eu já já fui
nesse legal eu já tive na França a gente
foi participar da 99ª Assembleia né da
ONU né E aí eu fui parar lá em Nova York
né e ainda tava até brincando com o
pessoal fala aí Zé eu tô em Nova York
nessa aí de Sarzedo tô em Nova York tal
aquela coisa toda né todos os é todo
deslumbrado Então mas eu consegui né
fazer essas coisas mas assim através do
trabalho então isso tudo veio atravessa
questão da transformação de vida e
quando as pessoas têm oportunidade
quando as pessoas têm ajuda porque
ninguém é sozinho ninguém é uma ilha né
muito hoje em dia Se Prega muito essa
coisa faça você ganha seu primeiro
milhão né seja o melhor não não não é
seu melhor mas é quando você tem ajuda
quando as pessoas te dão oportunidade
quando as pessoas te dão a mão quando as
pessoas é você também é solidária com
outras pessoas a oportunidade ela acaba
vindo as coisas começam a acontecer na
vida da gente né então hoje é além desse
trabalho da fotografia né que eu gosto
muito ainda faço articulação política
junto junto com os companheiros as
companheiros né lá do mncr lá do
movimento nacional dos catadores né é
trabalho viajo né trabalho com a questão
da coleta seletiva né De vez em quando
eu tô lá no galpão igual apresenta eu
moro em Sarzedo Minas Gerais eu comprei
uma casa lá né através de tudo alto
através desse trabalho é que eu consegui
a construir na minha vida né tem uma
filha de 24 anos que segue no espaço ela
é fotógrafa também aquela coisa toda né
moro com uma pessoa maravilhosa né a
Dona Cris né hoje ela é professora e tal
quer dizer eu tenho minha vida eu posso
dizer que eu tenho uma boa vida né fala
assim ah mas você ganhou um dinheiro não
não não ganho não ganha não é a questão
financeiro como a gente fala é a questão
é do Bem Estar Social a questão é você
poder fazer as coisas a questão de você
poder viver é a questão de você poder
ter uma garantia que você a vida tá
passando e você olha para trás você fez
alguma coisa e tá fazendo alguma coisa
né então isso é muito importante a gente
dá oportunidade as pessoas abraçar as
pessoas é entender a dor do outro da
outra né isso Isso faz parte né então eu
fico muito satisfeito e essa
transformação de vida foi graças ao
trabalho com a questão da coleta
seletiva a questão do meio ambiente né
então a gente por exemplo a gente tem
uma escolha e é hoje o planeta está se
transformando a gente Está transformando
a gente se transformando ou o meio
ambiente tá aí a questão do aquecimento
global nessa questão climática a gente
tá vivendo uma seca Severa no Brasil né
os cursos da água tão poluído os oceanos
são cheios de plástico né então a gente
tem que ter esse entendimento que a
gente tem uma escolha para fazer hoje né
a gente tem uma escolha para fazer que o
mundo que a gente quer qual a direção
que a gente vai tomar né Assim como eu
tive essa escolha há muitos anos atrás
né eu tive essa escolha eu tomei um rumo
né mas é isso então a gente tem que
fazer a nossa parte a gente tem que
começar a pensar começar a refletir né
começará a entender que a gente tem uma
escolha EA escolha que a gente quer o
seguinte que o mundo que a gente vai
deixar para os nossos filhos e filhas
que os nossos netos que planeta que a
gente vai deixar né a gente vai
conseguir vai continuar nesse consumismo
desenfreado a gente vai vai continuar
poluindo
e vai continuar só comprando comprando
comprando comprando e descartando me
descartando e comprando e comprando e
comprando né então a gente tem muito que
pensar nisso né então a gente falou que
a gente fala é para as pessoas né é
praticar a coleta seletiva né não é só a
coleta seletiva presente que vai
resolver o problema do planeta né mas é
o retençao reutilizar né as ações né
Isso tudo que vai fazer parte de uma
grande transformação né então o que a
gente tem para falar um pouco isso aí a
minha história de vida um pouco é um
pouco ligado essa questão mesmo da
reciclagem a questão da transformação de
vida né E hoje eu posso dizer que é o
seguinte eu me sinto realizado eu me
sinto
satisfeito né Eu tô com 47 anos né e eu
espero que eu Viva Mais outros 47 anos
né quem sabe eu quero acabei velhinho lá
com 99 anos 100 anos e tal e olhar para
trás falar não cara eu ajudei
como criar um mundo melhor eu ajudei
trânsito fazer transformações de vida né
eu ajudei pessoas também do mesmo jeito
que eu fui ajudado eu ajudei pessoas né
então hoje hoje eu sou grato eu sou
grato pelo que eu tenho né quando a
gente fala o que eu tenho não não a
questão material Mas o que eu tenho de
experiência de vida o que eu tenho de
conhecimento né as pessoas que eu
conheci e que eu conheço ao longo dessa
trajetória dessa caminhada né são
pessoas é tão pessoas importantes na
minha vida né Os catadores as catadoras
é muito é muito partiram né se foram
dessa vida mas tá aqui no meu coração né
as pessoas que eu trabalho né então a
família né meus amigos vizinhos então é
a gente sabe que a gente faz parte de
uma grande aldeia global né E essa ô
Débora bola precisa ser transformada e
esse é o recado que eu tenho para dar né
e eu a oportunidade aí o tá podendo
passar essa mensagem para vocês o